I took your girl to me this one time she
does I feel eggy
well you gotta get out that's so
disgusting it's so disgusting and my
boner went you know what I'm out that's
a disaster then just remind me cuz out
of carry I almost said I feel egg you
know egg cakes like my brain went let's
let's go throwback Thursday that time
you almost threw up in your mouth when
that [ __ ] said I feel eggy before you
guys are gonna have sex all Turkey have
you ever spin in a gym well I was in a
very quiet hotel gym lie and I was want
to work out okay and this this weekend
uh-huh and guy comes down and goes do
you go I just go he's stretching right
and did he say I feel immediate I feel
me he starts working rounded yeah yeah
I'm feeling real me you know what I feel
meaty gonna pull out peel your dong I'm
feeling me this watch he bow yeah that's
the noise you make this guy was working
out he was doing this he was he doing
work done no [ __ ] no he's on the
machines like I was like distant I will
when the throat for [ __ ] that's right I
don't know her headphones I got right
now I was just like [ __ ] this it's my
[ __ ] her headphones day what are you
doing dude I don't want you to make sex
with shape though no no he was that he
had a long yoga body he had super short
legs if [ __ ] penguin he was a man
penguin with the longest tour saluting
black guy right no right no white a [ __ ]
yeah no [ __ ]
yeah yeah I'm not a black guy just like
[ __ ] I was like your how do you have
first of all use like six four and he
had legs that belonged on someone we
judge in this guy's way judges guy
trying to get better dude I know man I
gotta give love something it looks like
your core
he was at the body of your court he was
some man Corky the man Cory [ __ ] man
Gorga - got him out there first went I
feel me you know what I can is there a
machine for this yeah and just pull out
my three pieces now I guess suck I feel
me D is there is there a sock machine
God you could do that with your boys at
the club psyche God fellas I feel me D
well yes uh can you imagine if the world
was made of people like their parents
and used to be what the music they used
to on their end of alter beautiful it
used to be though I don't know what that
is right but we're still pretend that
never happened
thank God dude speaking a different
check out my [ __ ] cage dude those are
terrible now do they come up with Trejo
transformer
[ __ ] robot because well no what are
you wearing know you old thought are you
wearing this is the shape of Mars and
they have NASA inside and if you take a
picture there the moon I don't
understand Brendan you have business
socks on I don't expect you a well I
don't really appreciate those well you
know who makes them Brendan Oh small
company called Nike when they expensive
I don't know I don't see dollar sign at
price X I it looks forward to me now
house will be in China
your wretched muscle being Chinese that
well let's not show my girls titties why
not girls god she's something else
your son's no like your son's neck is
first of all my son took this picture by
the way so look and then put on the
flash girl the next boom we on the moon
baby
wow that's pretty impressed yeah you
like that [ __ ] you'll [ __ ] know so you
got thought about hair is yellow shoes
what I know those are different just
three pairs that be the same pair bro
that I took a picture of the camera
how filters work now saving a filter
[ __ ] flat sided camera Oh younger
know it easy man take it easy
don't be such an Aegis younger okay man
Oh dope sneakers brah oh those are dope
sneakers brah
Ruff's Khalifa Wiz Khalifa know where my
Ezz check up
I have my checkup from my doctor morning
what I know it's not true at all I'm in
the doctor in forever
G I had shingles vol your skin is yeah
alright but other than that I had a
check-up that I had a check-up in a year
and a half yeah and daddy cholesterol
back down oh yeah how'd his cholesterol
is down I got any stick those old digits
up the rump er no they don't do that
anymore they do it you were to I was to
do a blood test for really they don't
have to go check this anymore and so
here's the other thing about that
sometimes I've they'll find if they find
like like a high PSA account or like
whatever I'm trans dating thing they'll
do a biopsy here's a problem with a
biopsy you go impotent a lot of times it
[ __ ] you up a lot of times so getting a
needle in there and taking all that
tissue is not a good idea so they don't
do that as much you know it's very
common to do it though right they do it
but like the kind of newer got the
doctors that are more up on the
literature gonna you put our fingers
there are better ways to do it
never better always do it you think they
focus more on that than like say curing
cancer just because the doctors were
sick upon fingers in it well
cardiovascular and colon colon cancer
and your cardiovascular that's where
that's what the first then six percent
of cancers are the other ones would they
say did you like brain cancer all those
terrible things but they say to you
Aarthi um daddy's daddy's what's the
word super healthy daddy's like that
he's like like the guy goes 52 he goes
how'd you like us Wow he's 45 young
young yeah 43 he's all about like
nutrition and all that stuff I mean he's
really interesting so you're all good
why'd you do the check but I did but he
didn't test I've never had done like
what like like your ratio of omega-6 to
omega-3 fatty acids that have a
correlation to heart disease and
I've never done that yeah fish well he
told me that so your DHA s and your eh
A's are the two ones you you should have
about a thousand milligrams so 500 on
each but a lot of fish oil has very low
th and EH a or whatever so but I took
four or krill oil from on it today
thank you very much and I had I've been
doing that but every scientist I know
who's into this they do take fish oil
fish oil yeah
official CBD oil that's the one thing we
have way to say good so what is your
schedule blowhole oh they the worst is
how was your day it's like also me to
recap what I just did my favorite is
this so for the summer oh my god excuse
me
three months from now here's me well no
I don't know two days from I don't know
anything don't talk to me about the
summer you know it's a trigger for me is
when people try to plan a vacation
I'm talking a trigger Oh Padre you don't
even know I'm so why because I'm on
vacation with my sister my friends and
my friend's wife and my sister were
talking about occasions while your
application I'm on vacation and they go
so next you can I go I don't what don't
you drama hold on I'm gonna ruin this
week I don't know if I'm gonna be alive
I know
god I'm on vacation when you're on
vacation the [ __ ] man don't know moment
I can't plan it's a real trigger for me
vacations when someone goes man you know
what you should go I go
Oh God [ __ ] you man I don't know what it
is yeah let's talk to someone about it
so realizing I think that your vacation
if this is me I think you would like
going to Europe yeah if you let me work
and then like and then after I'm done
doing shows I'll pop on over to it's
like Franco is going to Croatia then to
the Amalfi Coast then to to like
Florence to shoot a movie and live in a
castle that's let's get Billy Corgan
back and talk about it yeah I was
kidding
what else we got scary experience Josh
can a romantic man chokes ghost or
cashier for smash the bag of chips
I get it bro so there's a man
was that a grocery store he had his
items checked out and the bag boy kept
on tossing around his items not
necessarily just his chips but he put
the chips in the same bag as canned
goods is he all there it was a messy
stable dude he says he is coach about
Jerry now put your bread on the bottom
that's right put your soda on top of the
bread yeah carry on but the guy says oh
he was having a bad day he snapped on
him because he did it in front of the
man's wife so he felt disrespected by
the bag boy he confronted the bad guy
and he ended up trying to choke him out
to which police came and arrested him
but he said it's just because he was
having a bad day cool wow dude some type
of [ __ ] happened you have a bad day
you'll freak out you know I fired off an
email the other day I was on a bad day I
fired off an email like oh well can't do
that even chin text me back like maybe
don't send that type of email maybe talk
to me first
yeah my brother did you see yeah yeah my
brother goes what's wrong with you that
just [ __ ] dealing with this business
stuff and I went I descended the email
feel bad you know so let me read the
email and Jay goes we can't do that you
simply can't do that
here's if you work for my coming you'd
be fired did you did you call him and
tell him you're sorry yeah I did why
would I give that to you as a gift it's
a gift it's a gift